as we enter a new season we've noticed a
record number of car crashes this week
many of which have been deadly Madison
Kimbrough spoke with many who say safety
on the roads is really a must for them
she joins us live near flamingo in
Sandhill tonight where one of the most
recent crashes happened Madison
yeah the crash that happened here on
Friday morning was not fatal but the
victim is said to be on life support
that's according to Metro this
particular crash involved a motorcycle
and a car as a motorcycle rider was
ejected from his bike then a couple
hours later another accident this one
was fatal occurring on West Centennial
Parkway at the intersection with North
Hualapai way the motorcycle rider did
not survive unfortunately another fatal
wreck happening that Friday afternoon on
Las Vegas Boulevard in Sloan Nevada
state patrol conference drivers involved
were taken to UMC but later died we
spoke to those who say driving across
the valley has become a chore due to the
frequent accidents and careless drivers
around
everybody here is from different places
so nobody knows how everybody drives
everybody's just completely crazy and
then you have the intoxicated drivers
people they don't care they don't care
currently Nevada has lost close to 250
lives due to fatal collisions on our
roadways this year with the main
contributors being impairment and
speeding that's according to Nevada
office of traffic safety again the
accident here on Flamingo and Sand Hill
has not been declared fatal but the
motorcycle rider involved is fighting
for their life at this time now the
other driver involved we don't know
their condition reporting live Madison
Kimbrough 8 News
now that crash near Centennial and
Hualapai marks the 106th traffic-related
death in Metro's jurisdiction this year
though the total number of lives lost is
down nearly 3 percent from 2021.